holy crap everybody we got our dominoes
so I'm going to explain what's going on
in the comic book teaser that Ryan
Reynolds dropped so Logan giveaway is
going on right now I'm giving away
tickets to the movie all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so if you didn't
see the teaser that Ryan Reynolds
dropped he was pretty crazy about it so
there were two pictures one said the
domino effect in the dominoes were just
made to spell out za z beats C actress
that they had cast so it was a casting
announcement then a little while after
that he dropped like another teaser
picture that was based on the Mercs for
money that had the za z beats effect so
I'll explain what that comic-book teaser
means and what za z beats means because
she's a really solid pick and she's
definitely in their price range the good
thing about Deadpool is is they're not
turning it into like a 300 million
dollar blockbuster movies stuffed with
like 20 billion characters that while
Marvel may be able to pull off the other
Studios just haven't been doing a good
job with in the thing about Logan that
everyone's loved so much is the fact
that it's focusing on a few characters
and you actually get to spend some time
with them so feels like boxes definitely
learned the correct lessons from their
success and even though Deadpool 2 is
going to be crazy as hell they'll be
doing mercs for money team-up stuff it's
not going to get so overblown that you
lose sight of the characters but za z
beats if you haven't seen her she was
just on donald glover atlantis series he
won a ton of awards for that creatively
it's actually a pretty solid series but
there weren't that many episodes and
there's actually this huge break
happening right now because of all this
Han Solo Star Wars stuff there's
actually a really cool Marvel Cinematic
Universe Easter egg in here too so
everybody knows the Russos that marvel
are blowing things up with infinity war
now they're like the kings of the Marvel
Universe so way back at the beginning of
community Dan Harmon was casting the
show the Russo brothers are the ones
that told him to cast Donald Glover who
they just had the clairvoyance to see
would become a huge actor someday so he
goes on to Atlanta so za ZB flows from
this really crazy pedigree so before
Deadpool Drock shall be in another small
horror film but it won't be anything
like Deadpool so if you want to check
some of her stuff out check out Atlanta
season 1 the cool thing about Domino is
that she actually debuted in a funny
roundabout
in New Mutants number 98 the same issue
the Deadpool debuted although
technically it wasn't the real Domino it
was actually copycat who was
impersonating her now you know they
changed Vanessa which is her real name
for the movie so Vanessa copycat in the
movies is not a shapeshifter the way
that she is in the comic books but the
real deal Domino debuted a couple years
later in a flashback during x-force
number eight so for the most part she's
an x-force character sort of like an
r-rated version of an x-men character so
that's the way she's been drawn you look
at her for most of her publication
history she is a young dude wet dream
come true like why don't all the x-men
look like this suddenly you all remember
that there was a time when x-men
actually did swimsuit issues that was
one of the funniest stunts that they
ever did but I definitely bought it when
I was a little kid her powers and
abilities are actually pretty cool it'll
be fun to see how they play with them on
the screen but she basically has the
power of good luck so what it is is it
sort of like a probability field that
she extends telekinetically from herself
it also gives other people around her
bad luck so think of it as like the
storm troopers not being able to hit
anything curse so if you were running
from a hail of bullets then she would be
able to extend that telekinetic field
none of the bullets would hit her but it
also heightens her senses so she's a
really badass assassin on top of that in
the way that Deadpool was an assassin
before he got his powers too so the
characters share a lot in common they
were like a brief thing in the comics
for a little while but usually Deadpool
especially in his early days was
associated mostly with copycat but
Deadpool is one of those characters that
he just pair with a lot of women because
they put him in so many titles like he's
with shakeela right now but there was
outlaws there was deaths I know
everybody talks about Deadpool and death
because of Santos and death in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe a lot of
questions there don't know if they'll
ever get quite that meta with the
Deadpool movies
I know cable is going to be a big thing
in the movie Deadpool on cable faced off
against each other in New Mutants number
98 but when Domino was created like when
she actually became a character and it
wasn't the fake version of her that was
actually copycat she went on to join a
team called six-pack where she met cable
and they were working jobs for Toliver
the same person that hired Deadpool to
kill cable
his original debut issue during the
mission cable gets them to break their
contract with Tolliver but then in the
heat of battle cable bails on them
leading to this huge rift between Domino
and cable later they buried the hatchet
she joined x-force the team that cable
had formed she was actually there when
cable found out that his mother was
secretly Madeline Pryor the Jean Grey
look-alike eventually they get paired
off they have something of a
relationship
then later she rejoins x-force with
Wolverines team which was like a way
more hardcore version like the more
modern version of x-force no we're all
hoping for Wolverine to come back but
not expecting Hugh Jackman to walk that
back so x-force is actually coming up in
the movies they already confirm the
Deadpool and cable will be the leads of
the x-force movie that they're making so
obviously it's going to flow straight
from the comic so if you've read the
original x-force comics in the story
about how Deadpool joins they'll be all
kinds of Easter eggs for that they
always change the comic book stories
just a little bit though
so she's just a really badass r-rated
version of an x-men character that does
have tragedy in her past she flows from
the Department K which is the Weapon X
offshoot that Deadpool was made in she
has the tattoo over her eye that's not
like a birthmark or anything that's
something that was left by that original
Department k program in for a little
while after she was first created she
had a husband that was killed so they
might give that to her some of her patos
because they did give most of Deadpool's
classic origin story to him even though
they condensed it they cut a bunch of
characters out so we can talk more about
Domino as we get closer but all this
Domino craziness just means that they're
getting ready to announce their cable
they're like riot around the corner so
either it's going to happen next week
the week after that because they're
going to be shooting the movie really
soon but the Mercs for money teaser so
you may have spotted that cover a bit
like that looks kind of familiar so ever
since last year there's been an ongoing
title called Deadpool's mercs for money
with a bunch of characters dressed up to
look like him he was inspired to create
a team but at first he calls it Heroes
for Hire so Luke Cage ended up suing him
this is all happening last year so if
you saw the Luke Cage Netflix series too
chuckle a little bit and think about the
meta situation whereby he Sue's Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool for impersonating his
team so during the
Civil War two story line they went on a
bunch of big adventures but they found
out that Deadpool was skimming money
from them so they all disbanded by the
end and then Domino reformed her own
version of the team so it's Domino's
mercs for money so what they might do is
a version of mercs for money in the
movies whereby Deadpool builds a team
around himself and it all goes to hell
because he's terrible at organizing
stuff he is the worst person imaginable
to lead a team that's really where cable
comes in because he formed x-force they
were actually a very successful team for
a long time so what they might do is a
failed attempt or like a bit of a
tongue-in-cheek attempt at Merce for
money during Deadpool - and then
actually spin that out into a real
x-force movie where there's an actual
team that goes on to their own franchise
but the cool thing is you all know how
the movies are starting to influence
what they do in the comics now negasonic
teenage warhead just became part of the
mercs for money
in a recent arc from a couple months ago
like literally just a couple months ago
so even though Deadpool is a Fox
character they're trying to tie
negasonic teenage warhead from the
movies to his comic book character just
because they hope people see stuff in
the movies they want to read stories
with those characters so they try to do
that as much as possible whenever it
works in fact they actually says that
Marvel comics is going to be advertising
its comics in front of some of the
movies that are coming out this year so
when you go see guardians of the galaxy
they're supposed to be advertising for
the new secret empire Captain America
arc which is going to be like the big
Marvel event later this year so Zod Lee
beats Domino it's going to be a lot of
fun in the movie she's going to be a
crazy character so let me know what you
want them to do with her going forward
because it sounds like she'll go on to
x-force so now that we have sort of like
the Deadpool side of the x-men universe
building out those just be plenty of
places for characters to go if they
don't show up in every single Deadpool
sequel themselves in related news if you
guys didn't know iron fist
the entire series is dropping at the end
of next week there's a lot of drama
surrounding it so if you guys want me to
do a video explaining what's going on
and why everyone is going crazy about
iron fist I will do a video about that
but they also just cast someone for
infinity wars that's going to be part of
the Obsidian order so that is a huge
deal and there
a new Wonder Woman trailer that's going
to be dropping tomorrow we might get our
first look at Aries so there's a whole
bunch of comic book stuff happening in
the next couple of days believe all your
Deadpool aren't busy comic requests in
the comments below next video is going
to be Star Wars to last get out I'll try
to get that out as fast as possible I'll
be talking about Finn Jedi stuff when
you wait for that click here for the
Game of Thrones season 7 trailer and
click here for that for Ragnarok
previews thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys in the
next video
you